if you can wait a year you can make a
ton of money like if you can do
something for 12 months you cannot need
for financial goodness pretty much for
the rest of your life I'm not saying
you're gonna be hella rich but you're
not going to need for anything if you
can wait 12 months if you can wait 10
years for an outcome be able to do the
doing without seeing the result for 10
years you will be able to be above most
achievement of most people and if you
can wait a lifetime and you don't even
need to see the result of your doing
this even while you are alive but know
that it may get done after you pass I
believe that you can change the world